la question de la surpopulation
carcérale c'est évidemment une question
de dignité et la CEDH comme beaucoup
d'autres le pointe c'est aussi
évidemment une question du sens de la
peine et ce que la prison fournit comme
service à la société dans le cadre de la
lutte contre la récidive
[Musique]
j'ai été moi-même surprise par le nombre
d'acteurs et d'actrices de la chaîne
pénale qui disent la nécessité
aujourd'hui d'un mécanisme de régulation
carcérale contraignant ils en appellent
le législateur le pouvoir politique à ce
courage puisque aujourd'hui il constate
que toutes les mesures prises de manière
individuelle ne permettent pas et bien
une déflation dans le temps nous sommes
opposés au système de régulation
carcérale et alors je veux le dire ça
n'est pas une question de courage comme
je l'ai entendu c'est une question pour
nous de vision politique d'abord il n'y
a qu'un mécanisme de régulation
contraignant qui puisse produire des
résultats c'est-à-dire quelque chose de
rigide et qui s'impose vous voyez pour
nous il y a rien d'évident à dire que
des gens qui ont vocation à aller en
prison n'iraient pas ou que des gens qui
révocation y rester sortent avant
mais c'est une question de justice pour
nous nous sommes attachés à l'exécution
des peines évidemment un vrai sujet de
surpopulation qu'elle sert à personne ne
peut le nier essentiellement d'ailleurs
et ça a été dit par notre collègue à
Bali dans les maisons d'arrêt on en
connaît un certain nombre moi c'est le
cas dans mon département où on a des
maisons d'arrêt qui sont encore
même si certains les qualifient de
familiales dans des conditions très
particulières
où on a encore des dortoirs 6 à 8
personnes dans une même pièce ce n'est
ce n'est pas rien avec au moment des
Assises des matelas au sol donc il y a
eu des condamnations donc je crois que
réellement quel que soit nos
sensibilités on peut mettre en avant ce
besoin de régulation il y a une façon
très efficace monsieur le ministre de
pouvoir pallier tout ça c'est de créer
des places supplémentaires de prison et
on va y venir mais ça fait partie
clairement de nos demandes et je pense
que c'est une opération vraiment manquée
aujourd'hui parce que la situation est
intenable la situation est intenable
cela a été dit par mes collègues mais
c'est vraiment partager je pense sur
beaucoup de bancs de la majorité
personne ne peut admettre l'indignité
que nous faisons vivre à des personnes
qui ne sont plus emprisonnées mais qui
sont sur emprisonnés et
captive dans des conditions tout à fait